[Musique]
bonjour ici monique janot qui vous parle
depuis le palais des congrès de paris où
le 23e salon de la miss vient d'ouvrir
ses ports c'est un événement qui attire
chaque année de plus en plus de monde il
n'y a qu'à voir d'ailleurs le nombre de
visiteurs qui se pressent déjà autour
des stands une heure à peine après
l'ouverture officielle
madame pourquoi venez-vous au salon de
la vie eh bien mon mari aime bien avoir
des amis à la maison dimanche alors
vient se renseigner pour voir un petit
peu les nouveautés la femme est partie
il ya deux mois avec mon meilleur ami
alors je viens essayer de retrouver un
autre peut-être pas trop blond on a
toujours rêvé d'avoir une amie d'enfance
mais vu les prix s'étaient pas dans nos
moyens alors on a économisé pendant deux
ans avec n'est pas nette
oui comme chaque année le stand du
meilleur ami est l'un des plus
fréquentés du salon à monsieur ces
modèles vous intéresse
oui bah écoutez je vous en prie essayez
là ça ne coûte rien voilà vous allez
simplement lui dire votre prénom
françois tu pourrais pas me prêter mille
balles mille francs ben voyons françois
on se connaît depuis trop longtemps je
sais bien je tolère ans dans huit jours
enfin sacré la chair j'espère que tu
repasses bientôt et puis pour gisèle
t'inquiète pas je t'ai pas vu alors il
est bien non vous prenez ces prêts à
réfléchir
merci approché venez essayer votre
meilleur ami
c'est exact le salon de cette année
s'annonce comme un très gros succès ce
qui je ne vous le cache pas est une
franche satisfaction pour nous
professionnels de l'amitié que cela
montre que la politique que nous menons
depuis maintenant trois ans porte ses
fruits
quelles sont exactement les axes de
votre politique m lamy est la portée de
toutes les bourses
lamy a toujours été propre inaccessible
trop rares qui avaient des amis je parle
de vrais amis qu'ai je vous le demande
un peu de gens quelques privilégiés
c'est tout eh bien nous avons voulu que
cette injustice cesse et nous lui sommes
efforcés de mettre au point des formules
très avantageuse qui permettent à tous
et à toutes
ta part d'amis et comme quoi par exemple
par exemple la formule week end est là
mais juste le samedi et le dimanche
mais qui vous fait quand même les
courses et la vaisselle pour tous ceux
pour les plus démunis si vous voulez
nous présentons
la ville de nefta qu'on appelle aussi la
bima temps alors pour une modique somme
de 5 francs vous passez trois minutes
avec un ami et vous emporter quatre
photos où vous êtes ensemble
ah ben oui c'est très agréable n'est ce
pas pour tous ceux à qui il manque une
pièce pour accueillir un avis de passage
voici l'ami livré avec ce sombre un gros
progrès pour les petits logements
l'auto a défendu par ici voici l'ami
fidèle
garantie 5 ans celui-là est à moins ça
fait dix ans que je les il a proposé ça
va je peux bien me lance aux trousses à
la nouveauté maintenant dont je suis le
plus fier cette année pour tous ceux qui
ont des problèmes avec le fisc
un fils en prison une légion d'honneur
qui tarde l'a mis en place et la bible à
sais qui je vous le rappelle il ya
quelques années encore n'était pas à la
portée de tout le monde donc le salon
cette année et sous le signe de la
démocratisation de la mise est de la
jeunesse est-ce que je vous le rappelle
là pour la première fois cette année
nous avons un stand copains qui remporte
le gros succès auprès des 10 15 ans et
bien je vous remercie
avec mehdi en plus grande compagnie
s'est arrangé pour tout découvrir bong
est en tout cas un salon très complet
les étrangers sont venus nombreux le
stand russe nous présente son fameux
camarades l'ami américain est toujours
très populaire mais qui sur le plan de
la vente subi un peu le contrecoup du
dollar à 10 francs 80 la grande
nouveauté du salon
les japonais qui on propose la machine
culture l'ami célèbre de votre choix
la voilà
et puis bien sûr une grosse affluence
comme chaque année au stand d'arras pour
le classique mais toujours efficace amis
bidasses eh bien je reprend l'antenne
car monsieur jean laporte secrétaire
d'état aux relations amicales vient
d'arriver pour inaugurer officiellement
ce salon de l'ami voici monsieur jean
alain potes là messieurs s'il vous plaît
en ces temps de crise
qu'y at il de plus utile qu'un ami rien
et bien ce magnifique salon prouve ce
que le gouvernement proclame depuis
longtemps que la france est une
inépuisable réserve d'amitié pital vous
l'avez vu comme moi monsieur jean à la
bottière d'autres victimes de l'attentât
c'est l'affolement
elle avait vu arriver je vous rappelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]